good afternoon of the rules
committee for Monday March
twenty fifth is hereby call to
order -- PC advice on audio
and video recording of today's
for seat is being made this
also being televised -- madam
secretary please call the
roll quickly here Cunningham
Carillo here flora Grayson
Kamlager-Dove Maienschein Mathis
quirk Silva hear from us here
previous yeah Wicks we have
we have a quorum we have a
consent agenda is our motion
that has an agenda motion
move of a shallow second by
Mister Mathis thank you very
much man sector please call
the roll Cooley hi Cooley
aye Cunningham Carillo hi
Carillo aye flora Lara I
recent person I Kamlager-Dove
of trying to Maienschein aye
Mathis aye Mathis aye quirk
Silva hi quirk Silva I wrote
most five from most I read this
riverside with I Cunningham
Cunningham I'm good --
of ms cam murder of
your and I on the
thank you thank you very much --
that motions pass and this rules
please enter thank you very